this is a rain forest in the east coast  of Madagascar this forest suspicion went  first because you can find in very  easily and into is beautiful  you can only find them here in this  place here five special things about  injury first injuries the biggest of our  livers second injury lives in pairs and  stay together for life third entry has a  very short tail is the only humerus  without the long tail  for entry is unique because every  morning the family sings together  you can hear the calls from four  kilometers away and fifth sometimes at  the end of the day they eat some soil to  detoxify we are seed in their food many  people believe that the lemurs are like  cats or dog no lemurs are primates and  we human being we are also primates so  we are close to lemurs so INRI are our  relatives